will finland and sweden joining nato
make europe safer despite warnings from
russia both countries made the decision
after the invasion of ukraine how will
the kremlin respond
this is inside story
[Music]
hello and welcome to the program i'm
muhammad zhum finland and sweden decided
against joining nato for many years both
have a long history of remaining neutral
during wars and staying out of military
alliances all that changed when russia
invaded ukraine leaders of the nordic
nations blamed president vladimir putin
for endangering security in europe for
finland the decision could mean
abandoning its policy of avoiding
confrontation with its enormous neighbor
russia's deputy foreign minister warned
of far-reaching consequences the kremlin
says it could send more troops to the
1300 kilometer border with finland but
becoming a member of the western
military alliance isn't guaranteed as
stepfasting reports from the german
capital
berlin finland and sweden will be warmly
welcomed into the nato military alliance
that was the message from all nato
foreign ministers at a meeting in berlin
except for one
turkey has made objections saying the
nordic nations are hosting what it calls
terrorist organizations pointing among
others at the pkk the kurdish workers
party to be frank i'm a bit confused
because i had a telephone discussion
with the president erdogan that is
approximately a month ago
and
actually he took up himself before i had
a possibility to do that that you're
applying for nato membership
and we will assess it favorable
i thanked him
and he was very pleased
receiving my thanks
for turkey there was nothing confusing
about its demands
they need to stop supporting terrorist
organizations the defense industry
restriction over prohibitions on export
permits imposed to an allies such as
turkey should definitely be lifted i'm
not saying this is a bargaining chip i'm
saying it as a requirement of alliance
russia's president vladimir putin has
called the possible northern expansion
of nato a threat
finland joining would double the border
between nato and russia but nato's
minister said putin has himself to blame
after invading ukraine they're confident
the issue with turkey will be resolved
soon
i heard
almost across the board very strong
support
for finland nato joining the alliance if
that's what they choose to do
and i'm very confident
that we will reach consensus on that
all 30 nato states have to approve the
admission of new members a process that
normally takes months but ministers in
berlin said they want to speed this up
to prevent the so-called grey period in
which finland and sweden would not be
protected by nato's article 5 which says
an attack on one is an attack on all it
was expected that as soon as finland and
sweden applied for nato membership the
process would be smooth and swift but
turkey's position may now have slowed
this down no one can say for sure when
the tumor flex will be added to this
collection step faster al jazeera in
berlin
sweden and finland have been official
nato partners since 1994 and have taken
part in several nato missions since the
end of the cold war let's take a look at
what they need to become full members
nato candidates must be democracies have
an open market economy and be able to
contribute militarily to the alliance
finland and sweden check all those boxes
have strong militaries and sweden is a
major supplier of weapons
once the application goes through the
parliaments of all 30 nato countries
need to approve new members
finland says it already meets nato's
target of spending 2 percent of its gdp
on defense sweden expects to reach that
by 2028.
[Music]
all right let's go ahead and bring in
our guests in finland's capital helsinki
owen mcnamara visiting research fellow
at the finnish institute of
international affairs in brussels in
belgium theresa fallon director of
center for russia europe asia studies
and in russia's capital moscow pavel
felgenhauer a defense and military
analyst a warm welcome to you all and
thanks so much for joining us today on
inside story teresa let me start with
you today i guess the big question right
now is will finland and sweden joining
nato make europe safer
well this has been a long time coming i
think with the invasion russia's
invasion of ukraine it has been a hinge
moment let's remember sweden has been
neutral for 200 years and this is a huge
change for finland as well so
yes i think that this will fill a vacuum
that's in that area
and the baltics feel a whole lot safer
there was a leonard mary conference in
estonia this weekend and everyone was
pretty much dancing for joy about this
event yes there's a small fly in the
ointment now with turkey but i think
that overall
both sweden and finland bring a lot to
the table in addition looking forward uh
also arctic security will be tied up
with the baltics as well so i think that
this is win for everybody and it shows
how upset and angry the public was with
the brutality of what's going on in
ukraine i mean daily news about russian
soldiers brutalizing civilians i think
something just
you know turned to switch in these
countries that were traditionally
neutral that they needed to join nato
that it wasn't good enough just to be a
partner that they needed article five to
feel safe oh and teresa there was just
talking about how historic this all is
that countries that have traditionally
been neutral would now want to join nato
i want to ask you from from your
perspective if sweden and finland do
join nato how significant a redrawing of
europe's security map would it
constitute
well it's
it's certainly
it's certainly historic
but uh whether it's whether it's all
that whether it's such a big thing well
it isn't it isn't i mean finland and
sweden i mean they both joined the the
european union in 1995
uh they have been politically aligned
since then with the european union and
with the west they've just been
militarily non-aligned but they've been
cooperating very very closely with nato
for many many years they're as good as
nato members essentially in terms of
their interoperability
uh their military operability and their
their political situ situational
awareness with the alliance uh they're
as good as nato members without the
article five guarantees so this
essentially just adds
an extra layer uh which would give them
nato's collective defense uh and access
to nato's uh nuclear deterrence so that
they're never
again alone to face down uh russian
aggression like we've seen in ukraine so
it would certainly redraw the map uh
of european security but particularly in
security in northern europe it would
make things crystal clear with um nato's
contingency planning in the region
and and this is good news not just for
societies in finland and sweden but it's
also good news for all the other nato
nations around the baltic sea for other
nordic states iceland norway and denmark
but also for the baltic states and
poland as well
pablo russia has said that finland and
sweden joining uh nato is a serious
mistake that it would have far-reaching
consequences and that both countries
should not assume that moscow would not
respond what kind of a response or what
kind of a retaliation would be expected
uh well moscow of course does not like
this at all and it has very vocally said
that this is a wrong move that this will
decrease security in europe and
decreased security for the two nordic
nations the russian foreign minister was
talking about possible count military
technical countermeasures but the
kremlin took a more softer approach
which actually is
typical for the russian policies in any
kind of
a century uh the russians are as always
the the peacemaker
so
the premium said well it will depend
what really happens there and today
on monday
the 16th of may president putin actually
said that we don't have any problems
with sweden or finland than them just
joining nato is also not much of a
problem too
teresa from your vantage point how do
you think the kremlin might respond
well it's very difficult to predict what
is in president putin's mind i think
that he has enough on his plate right
now with ukraine and
finland for example has already
experienced cyber attacks when they
first announced that they were
contemplating joining nato so i think
that there has been a lot of saber
rattling towards both finland and sweden
but i think they've made their own
calculations and they've decided to join
the club
owen when it comes specifically to
finland um do you think that this
decision means that the country is going
to abandon its policy of avoiding
confrontation with russia
well no i don't um
i think that dimension can still be
preserved within nato but one thing i
would like to say i mean
the view from helsinki is certainly
right now that russia has overstretched
itself and and that is the view of most
military analysts in ukraine so it is
very unlikely to pose much of a threat
despite its saber rattling right now to
finland and sweden it's from its
northern military district but of course
nordic societies if you understand these
societies it's all about the long-term
you know
stretching out prosperity for as long as
possible the next generation
uh and social development sustainability
of the nordic model and of course all
that needs to be secured so we don't
know in five or ten years how russia
might look like whether russia will be
more aggressive even more aggressive
than it is now or whether um it will
have gotten the right bloody nose in
ukraine and will have decided to to mend
its fences uh with the west and try
reintegration with the west once again
we just don't know and and the nordic
states finland and sweden they don't
know either so nato membership really is
to lock down their prosperity lock down
their
uh social progress
for the long term it's not really about
the short term even though as theresa i
think has said that uh a switch has
flipped but it but it is with a long
term uh
with a long term outlook if that is not
uh too paradoxical
pavel so oh
part of that but if i can just finally
if i can just just briefly uh
just
refine this to your question that yeah
and obviously in the long term uh
picture finland and sweden populations
are very very angry right now but if
russia wants to wheel back from its
aggression i'm sure both states uh will
keep the door open we'll keep the
channel for dialogue open to talk russia
out of some of its brutal aggression
that we are seeing in ukraine right now
pablo despite what russia might be
saying publicly just how concerned is
moscow about the possibility of finland
and sweden joining nato
well there's a practical thing that
russia cannot deal at the same time with
ukraine and
the the expansion of
finland and
sweden joining nato there's simply not
enough america capability for all those
talk about the military technical
measures being taken well not much can
be taken all the conventional
capabilities are more or less used right
now uh new brandishing the new queer
deterrent well yes it's there uh but it
was always been there so not much russia
can do and that's why president potent
was on monday 16th but may was very very
uh kind of a soft he said i would say he
said that we don't have a problem with
these countries if they journey to that
doesn't change anything much uh the
formality of joining but later on if
there's american because of course
russia is really uh zeroing on right now
the kremlin on america and the standoff
with the united states and nato as putin
says is an american weapon
aimed at russia
so american missiles or any kind of
other infrastructure appearing in
finland and sweden that means russia
will react again if it has the
capability and
and deals with ukraine or doesn't deal
with ukraine so that's kind of postponed
to the future right now uh russia will
not really do anything drastic there was
some fear expressed especially in
finland
uh that russia could use this grey
period when finland has applied for
membership but this doesn't yet have
the formality of the article five uh
guarantees that russia could make some
kind of move but that's not happening we
simply the russian simply does not have
the capability to do that right now even
if it did want to but apparently it
doesn't want to too right now
so uh it's going right now it's not
going further than a rhetoric
teresa
turkey has expressed reservations about
finland and sweden joining nato uh they
have objections and they've laid out
some demands i want to ask you
from your perspective is this something
that's going to present a major hiccup
when it comes to the accession of sweden
and finland to nato is this something
that could delay things or will
will everybody who's involved be able to
get past this
i'm based here in brussels and i think a
lot of people were rather surprised by
this because security is such an
important issue that all of these
conversations happened
for example the prime minister of
finland noted that they spoke to turkey
back in april and uh erdogan said that
they would support finnish
joining finland's joining of nato so i
think everyone's been taken aback by
this and it's not something you can mess
around with i mean if you give kind of
uh if you kind of assert that you're
going to join nato and then a country
blocks your
membership because nato you need
unanimity all 30 members must agree so
that turkey is kind of maybe
forcing them to twist in the wind i know
many leaders said that this is something
that will
require conversation that this is
nothing to be concerned about but i
think it sends a worrying message to my
mind
from turkey that there might be using
this as an opportunity to you know use
some leverage and get what they want but
i think that you know as an alliance
that's not really the smartest move at
this point and there has been a lot of
goodwill in in many respects with the
bayaktar the the incredible turkish
drones that they have been supplying to
ukraine so i think that um erdogan maybe
overplayed his hand at this point but
let's see maybe everything can be
smoothed over maybe there was a
misunderstanding but i think that you
know security issues defense issues are
are really very very serious and that
this kind of horse trading shouldn't be
done in public oh and it's being
reported that turkey's objections focus
on what it considers to be both finland
and sweden's leniency towards the
kurdistan workers party the pkk
it's a group that they consider to be
what they call a terrorist organization
is there a lot of concern in in finland
right now that this could delay things
that this could be a major hiccup
well it is true
um
that there is some sympathy uh towards
the pkk
from some sections uh of the finnish and
swedish uh political
systems but not all
we've seen
a trick like this pulled before by
president erdogan he did it just before
nato's 70th anniversary meeting in
london right at the end in december 2019
there was a lot of where he tried to to
do the same thing unless unless the rest
of nato recognizes the pkk as terrorists
then he would block extra defense
provisions for nato's enhanced forward
presence for the baltic states and
poland he's kind of making a domestic
point um
that he's not happy about the lie of the
land
regarding other perceptions of the pkk
within nato that that he's a strong man
as he always uh projects himself but
there's often a lot of diplomacy taking
place behind the scenes he was talked
down at the end of 2019 and the mood in
stockholm and the mood in helsinki is
that they have enough and there is
enough within the the alliance uh to
talk him down this time as well erdogan
uh and turkey are are quite isolated and
right now you know they're strategically
very important for western strategic
interests in ukraine as theresa has
mentioned but of course it is not in
erdogan's interest to be isolated within
nato either so he has to make a choice
oh and if i could also follow up with
you um if things are able to get back on
track now uh if things are able to be
smoothed over when it comes to turkey's
objections how long might the accession
to nato take when it comes to finland
and sweden
so
what we're looking at now in in the next
week or two we're looking at finland and
sweden filing their applications for
nato membership
it is likely then that
finland and sweden will be issued an
invitation to join nato at nato's madrid
summit in june and from there depending
on different parliamentary procedures
and different parliamentary protocols
because of course nato is an alliance of
consensus all 30 nato member states will
have to agree um there is no fixed time
limit on on this uh but the most um
ambitious uh or fast track uh perception
on this is that it could take as little
as four months from june and uh wider
estimates uh stretch that out to 18
months so 4 to 18 months seems to be the
range for the membership ratification
process
pavel one of the reasons that president
putin was so adamantly opposed to
ukraine joining nato was that he didn't
want nato on russia's border but you
know finland has a 1300 kilometer border
land border with uh with russia uh
sweden has a maritime border with russia
did president putin think that things
would go this far that he could be
confronted with the possibility of nato
getting to russia's border
in this particular way
uh walt finland actually joining nato in
moscow yes it was a bit of a surprise
because it was the relationship with
helsinki was always considered as a
privileged one since the soviet times uh
since after world war ii when finn won
during the cold war was basically a
russian soviet protectorate and
it was believed in moscow that that was
very good for moscow and good for the
finns well defense finnish people have a
very somewhat different kind of uh
recollection of those times they don't
like them and and the finnish military
as as the swedish military for uh
all the time they were always thinking
about defending against russian soviet
troops they were not having that they
were neutral but not preparing to fight
anyone else except
uh so there's different perceptions in
moscow and in uh those two countries of
what's really about what
they should do and what how they can
react
it's also important to notice that
russia for russia ukraine and for putin
ukraine is very special he has many
times said that ukrainians and russians
are the same people basically uh one
folk
and that they should be together and
pulling ukraine away from russia is
splitting their the historical russian
nation of course finland was also once
part of the russian empire but no one
really in moscow considers finns to be
russian
so there that's the kind there's a
different attitude they're seen as
foreign and also nato
had
in the in the beginning of the 2000s
taken in the baltic states that were
once soviet republics and they have a
border with russia and actually they're
closer to moscow than finland
and so that does not really change that
much in the strategic outlook though the
russian military the russian general
staff will surely be saying that this is
a big threat that they need more money
from the budget they should build new
bases they need new weapons this they'll
be playing up this thread
teresa um owen touched on this in an
earlier answer the the fact that both
finland and sweden essentially broke
their strict neutralities when they
joined the eu when they became partners
to nato in in the 1990s i'm curious from
your perspective would they have have
joined nato at some point anyway or or
was joining nato really a non-starter
until russia invaded ukraine
i think that they've had a very careful
balancing act and carefully cultivated
neutrality finland has a different form
of neutrality compared to sweden but
sweden historically as i noted 200 years
so two centuries putin's actions in
ukraine have upset their calculus they
realize they cannot be safe at this
partnership level with nato and that the
only thing that will keep their
civilians safe because it's overwhelming
it's about 77 of the population wants
them to join nato this is unheard of and
they want to do it together because
finland and sweden are kind of partners
in all of this and most analysts assume
that sweden would be first in finland
would follow but in this case finland is
really leading sweden is joining them
and it looks like it will be a joint
application but i think that
this shows that this is a hinge point in
history countries that for two centuries
were willing to remain neutral in order
to have good neighborly relations with
russia have recalculated that because of
this
horrific war in ukraine and they see the
brutality of russian soldiers so they
wants more safety and this is why
they're joining nato and i think that
the whole region you asked earlier about
the landscape the strategic landscape
has changed dramatically should this go
through uh you know some people have
described it as a nato lake the baltic
so you have increased security in an
area that kind of lacked uh was a bit of
a vacuum for security so this will
change dramatically and i think this is
going to be very hard for putin to
explain to the public that instead of
pushing back you know it's actually got
two new members
all right well we have run out of time
so we're going to have to leave the
conversation there thanks so much to all
of our guests owen mcnamara teresa
fallon and pablo felgenhauer
and thank you two for watching you can
see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story for me
muhammad jim jerome in the whole team
here bye for now
you